wackelpudding mit waldmeister geschmack
mit der natur hat das nichts mehr zu tun
denn der geschmack der kindheit kommt
aus dem reagenzglas
was mich jetzt mal zu ziehen würde wie
tatsächlich bald mal vor schmeckt
sebastian lege zeigt uns wie die
industrie mit künstlichen aromen unseren
geschmack formt und dabei eine menge
geld spart
[Musik]
seit über 200 jahren schwellt und
wackelt es auf unseren tischen ob
himbeere zitrone oder waldmeister die
grund rezeptur von wackelpudding hat
sich in dieser zeit nicht groß verändert
um diesen klassiker der
lebensmittelindustrie herzustellen
braucht man nur wenige zutaten bisschen
gelantine bisschen zucker aus dieser
grundmasse könnte sebastian jetzt
unendlich viele sorten herstellen am
liebsten macht er aber natürlich
weltmeister
das passt dass die klassische
wackelpudding war weißer farbe und der
geschmack liegt sebastian auch schon auf
der zunge ein paar tropfen aroma- und
zack wir denken wir liegen im wald in
dem feld vor lauter wald meister
natürlich ist an diesem geschmack aber
nichts mehr
lebensmitteltechniker haben der natur
ein schnippchen geschlagen und den stoff
cumarin aus dem wald meister im labor
identisch nachgebaut
herausgekommen ist sechs metern berlin
aber waldmeister wackelpudding ohne
weltmeister darf die industrie das
verkaufen nein denn waldmeister
wackelpudding müsste echten waldmeister
enthalten die industrie das produkt
daher typ waldmeister
so darf es verkauft werden übrigens auf
der verpackung mit das wort typ oft sehr
klein geschrieben das gesetz schreibt
den hersteller nur vor dass das wort
lesbar sein muss heißt für uns augen auf
bei der typ suche was schmeckt uns
besser natur oder labor sebastian nach
dem test neben waldmeister letzte zur
verkostung himbeer und zitrone antreten
mal sehen was den leuten besser schmeckt
typ oder natur
wir beginnen mit zitrone und himbeere
[Musik]
der arbeitsmarkt kindheit
und da geht man schnell ins minus
bei der dm pfennig geil werde jetzt
richtig richtig zitrone bei zitrone und
himbeere gibt es keinen klaren sieger
natürliche und künstliche geschmack
liegen gleichauf wie sieht es beim
altmeister aus
[Musik]
eigentlich definieren ein klares
ergebnis der natürliche waldmeister
geschmack geht mit null punkten komplett
unter unsere testesser entscheiden sich
einstimmig für das künstliche produkt
für sebastian ist das ergebnis nicht
überraschend und die leute kennen weil
meister wirklich nur durch diesen putt
was mich jetzt mal interessieren würde
wie tatsächlich weit mal fuhr schmeckt
himbeere und zitrone kennen wir auch in
ihrer natürlichen form weltmeister hat
sich dagegen der kunstgeschmack
durchgesetzt und unsere vorstellungen
klar verändert
für die industrie sind künstliche aromen
goldwert sie sind einfach zu verarbeiten
und deutlich günstiger als die
naturprodukte
da überrascht es kaum dass die
hersteller auch bei kaffee tee joghurt
und kuchen auf die künstlichen
geschmäcker zurückgreifen wie
wackelpudding erkennt ihr das durch das
wort typ auf der verpackung typ ist
nicht schlecht ist aber auch nicht echt
ist wenn sie genau wissen wollen was
drin ist dann schauen sie hinten auf die
zutatenliste und vergleichen es mal mit
den grafiken auf der verpackung
ihr wollt keine tricks checks und
ouellet zdf besser esser verpassen dann
aktiviert die glocke neben eurem
abonnieren -button